[Music]
what's up lyndon saginaw michigan how
are you
i'm great how are you i'm a [ __ ] i
can't work the phones i'm good how are
you
good good it happens it happens hey so
what's up how can i help
yeah so
my husband and i coach uh cross country
for a local high school good for you i
used to be a cross-country coach
yeah we love it we really love it we've
been doing it for a while now do you all
run with them or do you ride your bikes
with them
or do you all sit there and eat donuts
and yell at them and say go faster
none of the above okay um we run on our
own
on our own time but not with the kids um
so we've dealt with a lot of parents
over the years as you can imagine but
we're dealing with
a specifically difficult parent at this
time and have been for the last few
years i'm just looking for advice on how
to work better together with this parent
for the kid's sake because the kid is
being put in the middle of everything
that's right
so tell me about what's happening
um
the parent wants to be the coat
basically
um and not be the parent um
and my heart breaks for the kid
and my husband is
digging his feet in
on how to deal with it and i'm a
peacemaker like i want everybody to get
along and be happy um
i think it's best if we all just don't
talk to the parent and kind of just deal
with the kid but i don't know if that's
reasonable
so um so i was a high school coach for a
few years and i had an opportunity to
learn from a couple of masters um that
were really really talented and they
taught me about coaching and about
boundaries and about working with young
people and it's one of the great
blessings of my life mike gibson and
troy perkins uh
coach perkins and um
troy kai some of these guys were great
what i'll tell you that i learned from
them both of them all three of them um
were so great was this
number one at the beginning of the year
they had a parent meeting do you all
have a parent meeting
oh yeah okay
i watched them and again i'm 21 years
old i'm a kid i'm a baby and i watch
them get up in front and say here's our
goals it's academics right um it is to
instill discipline and hard work and
accomplishment all those things that
every coach says to every parent group
but then they would also add
we are the coach
you are not
right we will not engage with you what
you think that what plays we should be
running what workouts we should be doing
we are the coach here and if you don't
like the way we're doing it you are
welcome to pull your child out
there's too many other options these
days
and it was a very clear we will not
engage with you
um with
workout type plans with recovery type
like we're we know what we're doing and
we are the coaches
yeah otherwise the kid becomes the proxy
there and so anytime you get a
um
head coach let me put it this way you
can't solve this parent for that child
and that's heartbreaking isn't it
yes
it's hard when you're a teacher or
you're a coach and you run into that
parent who's just awful
and you know what they're doing to their
kid and you feel like you're going to be
the buffer that you're going to save
that kid and
often you're not
what you can do is love the heck out of
that kid
yeah and every time you see him or her
you make sure you're looking them in the
eye and tell them that they're special
and that they're unique and they are
strong and all those all those things
that coaches do coaches change more
lives than than
people would ever realize i'm sitting
here because of some coaches that
invested in me
but also you can't go to war with the
parent because the kid is the casualty
right right yeah and so somebody whether
it's you or your husband has to reach
out to the parent and say i'm not going
to engage with you on this
yeah and they're welcome to go to your
principal i wouldn't even put that out
there um i have had people call and say
i'm going to call the president and i'll
say here's their number feel free right
i'm not going to get into that yeah
there's been several
very stressful meetings with the parent
and the athletic director yeah so is the
athletic director in your corner
absolutely yeah so engagement time's
over
right we're done with that that's how i
feel just like what is also there to
talk about yeah we're done talking and
um it's with with the athletic
director's blessing i would send them a
note the next time they yell and if
they're parents that yell at you during
events you can tell them you're not
welcome at the event
period yeah and um it might be that they
throw a grown-up temper tantrum and take
their kid out of the event
unfortunately that's their that's their
right they're allowed to do that sure
and it stinks for that kid
and they will probably um probably
they'll just shut up because that's what
parents do they run their mouths and run
their mouths and then they just shut up
i got a talking to this year from a
little league coach
not for not because i was a mean yeller
because i was a fun i'm loud and i'm
always making jokes and cheering
everybody on and trying to have fun and
i would go to the dugout um and try to
pump up my son
and the coach said don't go to the
dugout any more parents and i wasn't the
only one but they said don't do that let
these kids have fun yeah don't coach
them on the way home let them have fun
they're they're they're ten right and so
i gotta talk to all so you know what i
did i just shut up and i started having
fun out in the crowd with the other
parents and we had a blast so that's
most of your parents
if you draw a line and they want to
throw a temperature and pull their kid
out then they're going to pull their kid
out they're going to find some other
school where they can parent coach right
yeah and every every season it just
comes to a
it comes to a head and it comes to a
meeting and i sit back and i just think
this is not what high school sports is
about it's not
just about winning and everybody
you know it's it it part of it is a part
of it's teaching competition and
you know being competitive but
we're teaching things that are going to
carry on later in life like discipline
commitment
you know and i just
struggle every year with this
looming
meeting that i know that's going to
happen but so i want to affirm you to
reposition the meeting
and i would love for you do you and your
and your husband
coach
yes well that's a wild setup have you
ever just like uh
rolled over in bed and been like hey i'm
not going in today you got it have you
just completely put them on blast before
that wouldn't go over well
uh that may have happened to me with me
and my wife were teachers but whatever
okay so
um
i want you and your husband to
sit down and get your principles of
coaching you all may have already done
this
why are we doing what we're doing how
are we doing this what are your values
as coaches and then when you have these
kind of meetings go in with your health
held high
your head held high
y'all are running the show you're good
coaches your kids love you y'all do a
good job are all those things true
absolutely yeah
and so when you're able to untether
because bullies can smell that
yeah they don't want that meeting and
they lean into that into your
and so flip it around i am completely
disconnected from a parent acting like a
four-year-old could care less what an
idiot child what yeah exactly what a
child right the same as you would do
with a five-year-old
you look them in the eye and say this is
what we're going to do today you can
choose to opt-in or you can choose to
separate yourself and that's how it's
going to go you all have a great week
and
they usually will complain about there's
no communication
or i've been reading this stuff and or i
ran and call it great that's so good
here's how we're going to do this and
here's our workout am i on am i am i on
the right track
yes you are
oh i'm starting to get like the the my
shoulders are clenching from when i used
to coach yeah um and
i have to remember that most the parents
most the time are incredible and they
love you and they're so grateful for the
role you play in your kid's life and i'm
not going to let one [ __ ] you know
blow it all up right now at all yeah so
if you and your husband can back out and
get on the same page principally and
values wise
then you can enter those things with a
totally flipped i look forward to those
meetings
because i get to say here's who we are
here's what we're about and we produce
winners on and off the track and that's
what we're going for right yep and
i know it's so easy to say because that
one parent can just ruin everything
right
yeah and it always happens during the
season when it's the worst time it's
distracting it's championship season
you know it's it's just not worth our
it's not worth our time yeah there it is
there it is
don't give it to him
yeah there's nothing to meet about we
will not meet about our workouts we
won't meet about recovery
um if your child is hurt then you can go
see our training staff
absolutely yes right and so i'm going to
take the parent out of that conversation
and i know that's going to be
frustrating for them especially if
they've been pushing people around since
middle school since elementary school
um yell are the coaches
and all of that will will change next
year because next year when you have
your parent meeting you can say clearly
we will not engage with parents on
workouts
we will not engage with parents on
um why and how we do recovery this is
how we run things if you have some input
you're welcome to go get certified and
become a coach too and parents if you
want to let your kid participate
go for it i think i've talked about this
on our podcast but here's something we
did my kid had um one of my children had
some
educational meetings that me and my wife
were a part of my wife is a nationally
renowned scholar
in this particular thing she has a phd
in it she's brilliant she is in another
state right now as a college professor
she they fly her in to teach this stuff
i also have a phd in education and i've
been working with people in the same
area too and when we met with our school
my my child's school
with a counselor with two teachers with
uh one of the assistant principals is
all great stuff just coming up with a
learning plan
you know what we asked hey what are some
books y'all are reading so we can help
be on your same page
we didn't pull any do you know who we
are do you know our expertise ah we
wouldn't be doing it like this because i
wasn't gonna serve our son what we wanna
do is support the teacher we wanna
support the school and if it's mayhem
and it's chaos and they're abusing my
kid of course they're gonna get involved
but when it comes to i think you should
run another speed workout instead of
just be quiet
just be quiet let your kids enjoy life
let them enjoy life
let them enjoy competition let them
enjoy competing let them enjoy i have
fun
and
while we're here i'll just tell you my
kids running cross-country
and sometimes i think man i think they
could do some more you know what i
challenged i challenged my son to a race
the other day and we raced
and it was almost embarrassing for me
because he's 11. and i consider myself
to be in good shape it was real rough
so if you want to have more fun with
your kid go run run with them ride your
bike with them do some workouts with
them
leave these coaches alone they're
working their butts off
they're working their butts off